bonjour maintenant le breton merci
d'être avec nous sur rt france une
rentrée des classes dès le 11 mai donc
mais tout le monde ne rentrera pas en
même temps c'est déjà certains selon les
mots de jean michel blanquer
quand le ministre de l'éducation parle
d'aménagement à quoi est ce que vous
attendez écoutez je pense que on est
assez peu nombreux à pouvoir dire à
commencer par lui-même en quoi
consistera et comment les choses vont
s'organiser
ce qui est frappant c'est la confusion
extrême
une fois de plus ce qui ressort du à la
fois du discours extrêmement floue de
monsieur blanc caire qui vient faire le
service après vente après le discours
lui aussi très vague sur le sujet de
d'emmanuel macron on a toujours ce
sentiment d'un hiatus d'une
communication qui ne fonctionne pas en
interne et donc d'une confusion totale
qui ressort lorsque monsieur blanc caire
essaie de répondre aux interrogations et
manifestement nous n'y parvient pas il
ne sait pas lui même comment les choses
vont se passer
cette date du 11 mai elle vous convient
les prématurés
que faudrait-il faire selon vous il me
semble que ce qui a terriblement manqué
et dans le discours de monsieur mâcon et
dans celui de jean michel blanquer
c'est de nous expliquer ce qui justifie
qu'à cette date on soit en mesure d'une
part d'envisager un déconfinement dans
de bonnes conditions
je pense en particulier aux questions
matérielles au matériel qui sera à
disposition de tout un chacun enfin on
est dans des des propositions ou des
annonces qui sont encore extrêmement
vague mais surtout qu'est ce qui
justifie qu'on commence par les écoles
c'est non seulement contre intuitif mais
tout
tous les spécialistes expliquent que
dans n'importe quel scénario de
déconfinement on doit des confiné en
dernier ceux qui ont été confinés en
premier et autrement dit puisqu'on a
commencé en france par départs confinés
par retirer les enfants des écoles
en toute logique on devrait terminer par
les écoles et par les établissements
scolaires et a fortiori les crèches pour
pour pour le déconfinement donc
aujourd'hui on voit que l'ordre des
médecins l'inserm alerte sur
l'incohérence que ça consiste et sur le
danger que ça représente
il n'y a aucune raison sanitaire énoncés
qui justifie qu'on revienne qu'on
commence par envoyer les enfants à
l'école tout simplement et en plus il
faut souligner qu on nous demande de
mettre d'abord les enfants les plus
jeunes et donc ceux qui sont le moins
capables de respecter les gestes
barrière dans un contexte il n'est pas
du tout sûr qu'ils aient des masques et
qu'on puisse leur faire porter etc
comment comment voulez vous mettre un
masque à un enfant de 3 4 ans et il fait
respecter des gestes barrières c'est
bien pour ça qu'on a commencé par les
laisser à la maison lorsqu'il s'est agi
de confiner justement les gestes
barrière comment les faire respecter
vous ne parlez des masses pour les
enfant certains professeurs également
s'inquiète du nombre d'élèves par classe
pour pouvoir respecter notamment la
distanciation sociale est ce que cela ce
sera possible à ce que des aménagements
vont être pris là dessus personnellement
je ne vois pas comment ça ce sera
possible
d'autant que on nous fait miroiter un
travail en petits groupes avec un
accompagnement personnalisé alors moi en
tant qu'enseignante j'ai appris à me
méfier de ce genre de formules vous
savez que ça fait maintenant quelques
années qu'on nous demande de faire de
l'accompagnement personnalisé en classe
entière de des classes de 30 élèves
maintenant
donc ce sont surtout des formules donc
qu'est-ce qu'on est derrière cet
accompagnement personnalisé personne ne
sait et surtout c'est éventuellement on
peut imaginer effectivement de faire
revenir les élèves par petits groupes ce
qui serait déjà moindre mal mais qu'en
est il des temps périscolaires des temps
de cantine des temps de récréation
moi je pratique dans un an je suis
enseignante dans un collège à
castelnaudary mais c'est encore plus
difficile à imaginer pour les petites
classes donc tout ça n'a aucun sens
c'est la réalité c'est qu'on a le
sentiment que dans cette date annoncée
il ya une espèce de 2,2 volontarisme
complètement déplacé qui fait que
finalement les et les enfants les élèves
les enseignants vont se retrouver dans
cette mythologie de un peu guerrière à
être au front comme on y envoyaient les
soignants sans qu'ils aient de
justification sanitaire encore une fois
qui permettent de rassurer les familles
mais alors qu'est ce que vous préconisez
si le 11 mai c'est trop tôt
pour vous c'est quoi c'est une rentrée
pour tout le monde en septembre par
exemple c'est ce que vous souhaitez moi
que tu es jeune et je ne suis pas
spécialiste de la question par contre
c'est effectivement ce vers quoi tendent
les spécialistes l'ordre des médecins a
l'air de considérer que rentrer faire
entrer les élèves avant septembre serait
déraisonnable
la réalité c'est que manifestement cette
ce retour à l'école a été décidé plus
tôt pour des considérations économiques
c'est une phrase que emmanuel macron a
prononcé qui me semble extrêmement
révélatrice est dit il faut bien que les
parents puissent aller travailler
alors je ne nie pas que la question
économique soit primordial à l'heure
actuelle enfin soit importante
néanmoins si c'est pour remettre les
enfants dans des conditions qui sur le
fond n'ont pas évolué par rapport au
moment où on est entré en confinement
en réalité ça reviendrait à les mettre à
les exposer à exposer des familles et à
revenir quasiment au point de départ au
point où on en est et quand on a décidé
de confiner
ce qui veut dire qu'on partirait sur des
sur de nouvelle vague de contaminations
et on reviendrait au point départ on
aurait confiné la population presque en
vain est pour rien donc tout ça est
absolument irresponsable chacun le sent
bien je crois que ça crée une
indignation parfois une colère forte
chez chez les parents qui sentent bien
que que les choses sont faites en dépit
du bon sens merci maintenant le breton
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes professeur de
français et membre du mouvement les
constituants